♪ ♪ ♪
- Tapis rouge pour la première
du film "23 décembre".
Beaucoup de gros noms,
beaucoup de budget; une comédie
de connaître un grand succès
dans les cinémas du Québec.
- Hey! Moi, j'ai acheté du
du beurre de cacao bioéquitable,
du pain fait avec des farines
que j'ai jamais entendu
parler de toute ma vie.
GUYLAINE TREMBLAY, comédienne
- Je voudrais tout d'abord
défaire eseseseseseseseseseseser
quelques intellectuels qui ont
fait des cours en cinéma déjà.
Non, pas du tout. On raconte
à tout le monde, des histoires
d'amour, de rencontres,
de deuil. C'est la vie.
à l'industrie et les soirées
comme celle-là ont été rares
depuis deux ans. Ce qui l l l l,
62 nouveaux longs métrages
québécois, documentaires ou
fictions, d'être projetés. . . é
948 000 tatatateurs; c'est 36 %
moins qu'en 2019 avant la Covide
àbababaisse cette année.vovovovn
par e,e,e, des films québécois,
à peu près?jejejejejejejejejeje,
peut-être.
- Hé, pas beaucoup!
(rires)
Peut-êpeut-être. Maintenant, ona
tellement de possibilités
de regarder des films
de partout dans le monde.
j'y crois beaucoup, beaucoup.
Oui.
- Chaque semaine,
Denis Hurtubise parle
sa programmation à la maison
du cinéma de Sherbrooke.
Selon lui, un film comme
"23 décembre" est une valeur
de salles.
DENIS HURTUBISE,prprpriétaire,
Maison du cinéma de Sherbrooke
- C'est écrit succès dessus,
c'est assuré.cècècècècècècècècè,
en termes de rentabilité?
- En terme'e'e'est un million
et plus.
- Mais les films québécois
aux guichets sont rares.
-  l l l'année, on cible à peu
près 5 à 6 films accessibles,
on dit large public, qui devrais
à un million et plus. C'est pas!
Astheure, on peut-tu travailler
avec les films qui vont fair, ,0
mille, puis les travailler
plus en régions puis avoir
une programmation plus ouverte?
- La Maison du cinrorororororors
une trentaine de films québécois
par année, y compris des films
d'auteurs aux sujets moins
accessib- On se le cache pas,
c'est pas toujoursssssssssssssss
si on le fait pas, ils aur
jamais les films à l'affiche!
- Mais le cinéma a 16 salles, de
la majorité des établissements.
c'c'c'est l'offre et la demande,
comme je le disais tantôt,
le nombre d'écrans nous
des décisions.
- Pourquoi avez-vous pas dit
à vos parents qu'on s'était vu
à S
vous ont dit quelque chose
contre moi?
- Non.
- L'an dernier, la SODEC a
de 49,5 millions de dollars
dans la production de sss
québécois. Alors que leurs
recettes en salles n'ont pas
partout sur la planète,
notre cinémai i i fait
travailler 3600 personnes,
est largement subventionné.
directrice générale, SODEC
- Les Américains ont pas besoin
de subventions parce qu'ils
à travers le monde. Nous,
on cherche notre place,
notre identité, notre discours,
qui nous reste et on n'est pas
prêts de l'abandonner.
- C'est qu'il faut que
de changement de lumière, parce
que t'sais, sinon...
- Pascal Plante réalise
Il procède au montage
de son 3e long métrage.
PASCAL PLANTE, cinéaste
- Il y adans tous les genres, às
les hauteurs de budget. Puis
en santé, à peu près, dans
toutes les sphères. Ça fait que
un marasme dans le discours qui
n'a pas vraiment raison d'être.
- Tu te rappelles-tu la première
fois que tu as fait
- Son dernier film, "Nadia
Butterfly", a été sélectionné
au Festival de Cannes en 2020.ns
de l'extérieur ont du cinéma
québécois, elle est vraiment
positive. Si on s'arrête au
box-office domestique puis
on dit : Ha, il a coûté
5 millions puis il a fait
200 mille, donc c'est un échec
retentissant. C'est faux.
J'ai fait plus d'argenten lices
internationaux qu'en box-office
domestique. Ça c'est de un.
Ensuite, tu as les ventes
t'sais, de vidéo sur demande.- e
d'avis que notre cinéma pourrait
- Est-ce qu'on peut faire des
sondages auprès de la population
pour voir c'est quoi qu'ils
veulent voir aujou? ? ? ? ? ? ?,
exemple au Québec, fait encore
très bien avec les téléromans?
- Arrêtez de chialer!
C'est la ga a a a a a a a a a a,
c'est pas une raison pour
se faialalal!
- Les Contes pour tous,
dans les années 80, ont fait
qui, aujourd'hui, à 40 ans,
consomment encore beau,,,
beaucoup de films, tous genre
de films, mais on n'a plus ça.
nos jeunes là où ils sont,dèdèd.
Les rejoindre sur toutes
c'est fondamental.
- Devant cet objectif de mieux
faire connaître ses films,
coup cet automne. Radio-Canada
ne diffusera plus le Gala du
cinéma québécois dont les cotes.
- Il faiaiait que les gens
fassent l'effort, mais justeisim
québécois, je suis garanti
qu'il y a des cellules qui
vont bouger dans leur corpququqt
quand ils voient un autre film.
- Un appel senti après deux ans
aujourd'hui une cinquantaine
d'écrans de cinéma de moins
qu'en 2019.
♪ ♪